very early on there was only one voice
in my game my own and this is my biggest
point to everybody this is why I don't
allow complaining or dwelling and for
people that want to [ __ ] with me because
no matter what I'm gonna point to
somebody who had the same exact sit oh
what you had a crackhead father and your
and your mom [ __ ] sexually abused you
and you got stabbed cool let me show you
this kid who actually had that exact
same thing and he won like what we're
talking about right now is the reason I
win I'm not worried about the little
details this is all macro blueprint
strategy mental strategy no matter what
we say right now P I'm gonna show you
somebody who grew up with the same exact
situation have different outcomes and so
for me everybody who's dwelling on their
shortcoming the bottom line is no matter
where you start
everybody has passed the winning and
losing for me the best move is to take
control your [ __ ] no matter how [ __ ]
up you are right now get rid of loser
friends and family introduce yourself to
positivity and winners and watch how it
plays out by the way that's the
punchline like this is a mental game
like there's just nothing else you're
not feeling it find new friends I'm
being dead serious about this this one
is real big for me who you hang out with
is a huge young again these are all
trying true things right we've heard the
your than whatever of the five friends
you spent like that's real that's that
one put in the bank please understand
that mindset is controllable in the same
way that all our opinions are
controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple and I'm
trying to figure out how to get this for
everybody cuz it is I think it's the
ultimate I lived in my own head nobody
had say when I tell you nobody [ __ ]
had say still to this day nobody has say
nobody has say very early on there was
only one voice in my game my own it's so
scary to me how singular my own voice is
it doesn't mean that I don't listen to
feedback it doesn't mean that I'm
delusional and I think I can get away
with bad [ __ ] and it's all okay
I could say something right now in this
podcast everybody under says I'm a piece
of [ __ ] and in my own mind I'm like
we'll see
it's very strange how I live life it's
it's way more extreme than you think
it's way more extreme than I think I'm
just like kind of like going through it
right now I'm like what the [ __ ] this is
crazy like it just means that I am
incapable of valuing anybody else's
opinion including my mom's my wife's and
my children's opinion about me over my
own if you realized how much of the
actions you do is to show your mom or
your dad or your sibling or your spouse
or somebody show somebody else that you
made it or you did it it is remarkably
scary how many people are dictated by
somebody else's opinion the whole the
whole game is broken because everybody's
too tied up into other people's opinions
I only care about my opinion myself I
think most people do [ __ ] for other
people I think most people buy the car
and the house for other people do some
people love the leather of a car or the
horsepower yes do some people like love
having a home that has nine rooms they
never use sure but you understand when
you're building something
you [ __ ] invest in the right things
as soon as [ __ ] possible the problem
is most people don't get to that because
they're as when something starts getting
successful they're taking the money out
and buying dumb [ __ ] I've never met
anybody who's been able to penetrate my
mindset and that includes my own parents
what's even crazier where I'm at now I
feel like I'm this manifestation I feel
like they made me but then I mutated
into something else I don't value
anybody's opinion about me more than I
have about my own self and it's a very
big deal there's nothing like it man
there's nothing like it I don't know
what else to say it is ultimate drug it
is the ultimate leverage exactly what
you're talking about that's exactly what
I'm doing
I think people people don't get it like
life's basic and we make it complicated
and it starts with being right in your
own mind it's such an inside game it's
an inside game there's add more people
with positivity and optimism and cut
people with pessimism and cynicism
who you surround yourself matters what
content you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different I just don't give a
[ __ ] what anybody thinks
now I equally care so much of how they
view me and what they think of me it's
pulling from opposite directions but
you've got to start with yourself
because when you're actually allowing
other people to get in you're vulnerable
[Music]